στην αστυνομία μετατρέψαμε τη μησή να στυνομία σεσαπόρτι σε γραμμή υποστήριξης γιατί δεν έχουμε ντεχνολογία
και γατί δεν έχουμε προσλάβει αυτό του ίδου στο προσωπικό αλλά ποιοι προαγόνται κάποιο άλλη
γιατί ίσουν τόσον έντονοςσμε τον τελιπαθεωδών καταρχάες να πω ότι είναι φίλος και γνωστός αποβαγιά
ο κύριος τοκιος τόσον και ιγωνένια του και τον εκτιμό αφάνταστα ανανθρώπο έχουμε διαφωήαιδενφανε του
ατίνφαινετο γιατί επαγγελματικά επαγγελεματικά τι ενο εγώ συνδικαλιστικά και αυτός από τη θέση του αρχηγού
αστυνομίας καταρχάσει φοβόταν να με συναντήσει φοβόταν να με συναντήσει φοβόταν να βγάλι μια φωτογραφία
δεν θα ξεχάσω χαρακτηριστικά υπουργείο δικαιοσίνεης αν να προκοποίου κίδυ να βγάλουμε μια φωτογραφία μαζί
με της συντεχνία και γύρισε και έφυγε και το φώναζεν ι και ς με διαψεύσει
κυριακοκιο εφώναζεν κύριο αρχικελαδι βγαλο μίτα φτογραφία με τε όνομα το θεβούπουτ φογόταν να μας
συναντίσει γιατί είχε μπείεση και ξέρω απου αθαίνεί εμπίεση είχε επίεσυ που άλλα συμφέροντα όι
να μηπάρξει ιθώ εγώι προσωπικά τους υλνλετάείχ πίεση που άλλους συδδικαλιστικούς χώρους ούτε μια φωτογραφεί
αν οότε να μακούει όταν το έβας δασικήζησης των προστάτευσα δύο φορες βγήκαν μπροστά που
κανένας άλλος δγα ν εβγαινε αυτές ει κι αφυρασ εποικοινωνίας δεν ξέρω και οι συνεργάδες
του πόσον το συμβύλεμαν να μας συναντά δεν υπήρχα από και περα τί περιμένεται να
εκαν να μεσα σεντικά λεμναφίζω αστυνομικούς να πεθαίνουν αστυνομικούς να τραγματίζονται η αστυνομία ε επιεναγκαλά
τι έπρεπε να κάνναμε να μη μήλαμε ανάλλά δεν νωρίτερα για σείσαστυνομίας ισωςν μην είχαμε
αυτά όλα που είχαμετα τους τελευταίοςμίες όπως λένε πολλύ νομίζω είναι θέμα προσωπο θομα λιτουργίας
γιατί τα πρόσωπα περιμένουμενα αποτελέσματα όταν να απατήσουν κουμια να αλλάξουν καταστάσεις οι τελέγες σε
ιάνυνοσήτεκόστασή τες τέκιως τ